so
um obviously generation now
you guys is a flagship artist uzi yeah
um
he's from your hometown um how did you
guys meet uzi i remember um
the first person that put me on to him
was was it was either will
from taylor game or ty sounds about
right yeah so
it sounds about right yeah i think it
was ty i think it was in boston with ty
and we're in his room and he was just
playing [ __ ] off soundcloud i was like
what is this
that came from us being on tour and with
those guys shout out to those guys so
ty is actually the first one that gives
you a show
oh wow like a real show in l.a his first
show you want to hear some crazy [ __ ] in
2015
i had a birthday show that burner was
supposed to headline in phoenix
and bernie couldn't show up and will was
like look man
do you want me to get who's do you want
me to try to get uzi to do it
and at the time i was like i don't know
if these people would give a [ __ ] who
little uzi is
right because they were there it was
like a real like it was like burner and
boz from dream it was like some rap [ __ ]
right i was like i was like i'll pass
like like don't make the call you know
and what [ __ ] idiot i am crazy but
but not but like
how did you guys initially find uzi uh
can you
take this off uh i was working at def
jam i was vice president
nr and um i wind up
a lot of people don't notice when i was
trying to dj i was trying to transfer
over
and doing edm dj and wise and i got
connected with this guy named sujit
and yes and scam he represented me for
about a year and some change
and he had me and just incredible you
know i seen just incredible
[ __ ] billboard i mean i was just like
holy [ __ ]
this is crazy so i i was like y'all want
to get in this circuit he was like i
don't put you on that same circuit so i
i started doing houston vegas and
atlantic city
my first atlantic city gig i think was
at mgm or something
uh i had to drive i had to fly in the
philly and drive to
atlantic city and when i drove to
atlantic city
i turned on the radio and i was
listening to diamond cuts yeah
um diamond cuts is a different story too
because i used to dj for miss jade
and when i didn't go on the road with
miss j anymore i seen diamond cuts one
time i was like yo you should
take over what i'm doing you know what i
mean
and so when i'm driving down there she's
playing just in the mix show and i heard
a song it's called the real uzi
and i was like yo this sounds special
what is this i call her immediately like
yo who was that
she was like yo it's just artists i'm
working with nate uzi vert i was like yo
i come back from lancaster i want to
meet him time went by didn't get a
chance um
but the next time it's like next time
you're in philly come up
uh what's another weird situation i
lived in
you know this area called east falls is
right off of ridge avenue they had a
next door
uh kind of little city called many young
and
i went home and i was like i want to
meet this kid he's probably in north
philly somewhere somebody basement
recording some crazy [ __ ] right
he's like yo darren man young so i was
like oh [ __ ] that's
walking distance from the cribs i went
to went to the studio
um listened to some songs he was in the
studio just silent as a [ __ ]
acting like he know
i was just you know he was just being
him
his guy uh i forget the manager name
damn
what's his okay buzz was there he was
just you know speaking for him
he just kept playing me crazy records
and i was like oh this [ __ ] crazy
so i go back to atlanta i tell them like
yo we could do this [ __ ] again because
at the time we wasn't really doing no
record label stuff drama was building
the studio
he was like yeah i want you to see some
[ __ ] down below you guys had you know
went down that road before
yeah we did the affiliates yeah and then
uh i i went to l.a was trying to figure
some
things out moved there for like 18
months didn't like it came back home
but me and john started communicating he
was like yo i want to show you something
you get back to atlanta
i came he was building uh main streets
uh
501 which is now the famous 501 main
streets and i uh
and i seen it and i was just i went in
the studio and he was asking me about
equipment i was like damn you gotta get
this right mike and
you know what i mean no speakers we
could do that and you know he had a
radio room
and everything was getting built out and
it was just special so i was like damn
as we started working and
i was i was coming to the studio more
regularly when he was doing stuff
and i was like yo i found this kid we
need to do this [ __ ] i'm telling you
this [ __ ] gonna work
right and then we was like [ __ ] we all
in we never really told each other no on
nothing
right but he was like yo this gonna win
and this is like our first time like
as the three of us because we're always
like making
drums relationship and ours was
different me and lake would meet up and
talk forever he would
get me so much money on the mixtape side
just hosting and
he would bring freeway over to the crib
and stuff like that and then
he was doing some stuff so we all
combined it you know what i mean and
then we we finally got uzi to atlanta
and i think his first he recorded in
january
he never left he just stayed i'm not
going back home you know what i mean so
that's how the whole play came together
and then we just worked on it from there
it was just
you know what was like the like was the
carnage record like his first like big
look yeah
yes yeah yeah cause i remember that
record like
just going up in the club and and and
that really being like i had heard the
name because of like
because of whale but i was like oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is yeah when i speak about
conviction
think about it when i was talking to him
and trying to get him into the fold
he was already talking to asap yams
already he was uh
kanye was interested through this kid
named charlie heath
charlie heat was working with kanye he
was trying to bring him there
um he loved him
uh uh rich the kid and him was get
it was in like a little space so it was
like you know it was a lot going on
at that time you know while we was
trying to figure out how he was gonna do
the deal
we still had a name i think we waited
like six months trying to figure out
what the name of the company was going
to be
yeah we did we was just like nate [ __ ]
anything just sign him and let's go we
didn't you know
it was just a tough just trying to
figure it all out because it was so
it was so sudden you know i mean even at
that time
i was trying to even though we was doing
it i was going to take our situation and
try to do it through def jam and that
didn't work out because it was just so
much going on
i brought so much talent to def jam to
just wind up not getting signed
that i just like yo it's time i learned
some stuff like who
uh i brought rich homie quan i mean uh i
told him about the amigos
i told him about uh iggy azalea very
early i uh i actually tried to sign asap
rocky
in the asap mob and when i couldn't get
them because it was already getting
ready to get committed
i seen that uh iggy azalea was there she
had a song called [ __ ] it was like
2011.
i sent the email it's like you know i
was in
wind up getting signed later it was just
so much random [ __ ] that you know
i was just telling them about and it
just didn't work out uh there was
something like
we dirk and rhys that there were some
that we kind of like nurtured
logic these are all the things that we
can
bring logically no oh my god noah
preston okay okay
but we all were like when we went to
cali was me him no id we're all like a
hub so we're just bringing things in
trying to work it i think uh
uh who was it janae aoki we just had a
mean
team we were like administration so you
know what i mean
so when we were we were doing all that i
was learning so much i was like yo we
can do this because i
already know how the buildings work you
know i mean we're in the building yeah
yeah
i knew for three years i was like oh man
i learned so much let's just go do this
[ __ ] outside you know what i mean
and i was just almost certain you know
drama
to atlantic yeah he was at atlanta it
almost took like the finding the right
artist to like
you know we had tried to sign a couple
other people yeah initially when we
first got going like
we took a couple trips and we we had
flown to see a couple people
and like we always had them like right
here and we would lose them at the last
minute and
that's why we were so adamant about the
uzi thing what did you anybody that we
would know that you want absolutely
yeah like i think the first one was ot
genesis
we did playhouse with ot one night night
on ot from a while back and i ended up
dming him
and um i think i overslept and i didn't
end up checking my responses and when i
woke up and and checked the next day i
think busted already hollowed at him
so try this on tori trying to sign tory
lanez yeah we met with sasha early in
the game right at um
what's the name of the seafood spot
right
about tory lanez uh the amigos yeah
amigos
wow you guys tried to so cause
um